we have a voicemail number on this show
here's an interesting voicemail
about something people have written to
me about before my disclaimers
uh let's take a listen to what the
caller has to say
hey david i've got a new year's
resolution for you
yes how about no more
of the disclaimers for idiots all right
you don't have to explain every time
that chris wallace is not our friend the
lincoln project is not our friend
fox news are not as blah blah blah
if people on the left are too dumb
to ever accept that maybe
someone outside of their tribe has
something reasonable to say from time to
time
do you really want them to be a
subscriber so
this is completely fair so they're
referring to yesterday i did a segment
where chris wallace said one thing that
made sense
and i kind of gave this disclaimer where
i said listen i'm not saying fox news is
trustworthy i'm not saying these are our
friends
all i'm saying is chris wallace said one
thing that that makes sense
um the reason i do those disclaimers is
for my own sake it's actually selfish
i'm being selfish when i do it and i'll
explain why
if i talk about um different plans for
health care and i say there's medicare
for all and there's this other type of
plan here are different types of plans
if i don't clarify i'm not saying i want
for-profit health right
if i don't clarify that i will get no
exaggeration 100 emails clogging my
inbox from people saying david how dare
you
how dare you support for-profit health
insurance
so the reason i give the disclaimer and
i say hey i'm telling you something that
exists
i'm not advocating for it i
will get a hundred emails when i do the
disclaimer i only get
40. all right it's merely greed that i
don't know it's not even greed it's it's
a
concern for my own inbox that's why i do
the disclaimers
i agree that it's sad i do um
but it is what it is and if you saw what
was going on with my inbox every day
you would also understand it we have a
great bonus show for you today
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpacman.com i'll speak to you on
the bonus show